بعض اردوغان من هجوم انقره على دمشق بعد
ايام من اسقاط سوريا لطائره حربيه تركيه
مؤكدا ان الحادث متعمد وان بلاده سترد في
الوقت المناسب
نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقشه في عنوانين
رئيسيين هل يمكن ان يتحول التوتر الحليب
بين سوريا وتركيا الى صراعا مسلح
وما هو دور كل من روسيا وحلف الناتو في
تصعيد او تهدئه هذه الازمه
اختار رئيس الوزراء التركيه رجب طيب
اردوغان البرلمانه مكانا للتعليق على حادث
اسقاط سوريا للطائره العسكريه التركيه قبل
ايام واختار اردوغان ايضا لغه لا تخلو من
التهديد والوعيد رسائل عتاب بعثها اردوغان
منها ان قواعد الاشتباك تغيرت وان الجيش
التركي سيتعامل مع اي تحركات عسكريه سوريه
على الحدود معامله الاعداء وان انقره ليست
في موقف ضعف وفوق ذلك انها ستستمر في دعم
الثوره ضد نظام الاسد
اربعه ايام انتظرها رئيس الوزراء التركي
رجب طيب اردوغان ليرد على اسقاط احدى
مقاتلات بلاده من قبل الدفاعات الجويه
السوريه فبعد جدل عقيم حول خرق الطائره
الحربيه التركيه للاجواء السوريه ام لا
وكيفيه وحيثيات استهدافها واحداثيات
سقوطها جاء الرد من تحت قبه البرلمان في
انقره ليعلن عزم تركيا على استخدام حقوقها
الشرعيه وفق القانون الدولي
لم نتسامح بحدوث اي اخطار امنيه تشكلها
سوريا على حدودنا وقواعد الاشتباك بالنسبه
للقوات التركيه قد تغيرت مع هذه المرحله
الجديده وان اي عنصر يقترب من الحدود
التركيه سوف يعتبر عنصر تهديد وسيتم
التعامل معه على اساس انه هدف عسكري
اما في بروكسل فالتام حلف شمال الاطلسي في
اجتماع على مستوى السفراء بطلب تركي في
اطار الماده الرابعه من ميثاقه للمره
الثانيه منذ تاسيسه للتشاور اذا ما شعرت
احدى الدول الاعضاء بتهديد لامها
نعتبر ان هذا العمل غير مقبول وندينه باشد
العبارات دعوني اوضح ان امن الحلف لا
يتجزا ولا يقبل التقسيم وفي خضم كل ذلك
كانت دمشق تتعامل ببروده دبلوماسيه مع
الحادث الذي وضعته في اطار الدفاع عن
سياده سوريا واكد الناطق باسم خارجيتها
اسقاط الطائره برشاش ارضي لا يتجاوز مداه
ثلاثه كيلومترات في معرض تشديده على خرق
المقاتله التركيه للاجواء السوريه اذا كان
الهدف الاجتماع عدواني الطابع فاطمئن
الجميع ان الاراضي السوريه والاجواء
السوريه والمياه السوريه هي مقدسه بالنسبه
للجي
هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من انقره افق
اللوتاش الخبير في شؤون الشرق الاوسط
بمركز سته للدراسات الاستراتيجيه ومن
بيروت ينضم الينا السياسي والاعلامي
اللبناني محمد عبيد ومن القاهره صفوت
الزيات الخبير في الشؤون العسكريه
والاستراتيجيه اهلا بكم جميعا وابدا معك
افق اللطاش من انقره لماذا
ترقب اردوغان اربعه ايام كامله ليرد على
سوريا وعلى هذه الحادثه الخطيره
تركيا كانت تنظر في خير طياريها وسلامتهما
واللذان كان مفقودين فالبحث ما زال جاريا
الى الان والنقطه الاخرى كما اشار رئيس
الوزراء ووزير الخارجيه بان تركيا تود ان
تتاكد من البيانات المتوفره لديها وان
تتاكد من كل الحقائق لكي تستيقن مما هو
متاح ومما يمكنها من التحرك بما يخدمها في
الجو العام وفيما يجري في تركيا بنسبه
لراي العام وهذا يمكن تركيا بالتالي ان
تخلق شرعيه دوليه لاي تحرك مستقبلي وذلك
بسبب اسقاط الطائره المقاتله التركيه من
قبل سوريا اذا فكانت هذه ايام تحضيريه
لعمل المستقبل
تركي وهي تركيا كما نعلم هي دوله تهتم
بالقانون الدولي
وترعاه وتحاول ان تاخذه بعين الاعتبار في
كل ما تقوم به بدلا منه تتحرك بسرعه
واتخاذ اجراءات قد تكون متسرعه ولن تكون
تنفع تركيا ولا الشعب السوري بنهايه
المطاف تركيا اخذت وقتها للتحري ولكن
عبارات اردوغان جاءت
فضفاضه الى حد ما وغير دقيقه ماذا يعني
مثلا بعباره
نحتفظ بحق الرد
هو لم يقل فقط بانه يحتفظ بالحق بالرد
ولكنه قال ايضا بان تركيا سوف تتجاوب وترد
على النظام السوري
وسوف تحدد الوقت والرد وكيفيه الرد هذا
يعني بان تركيا ليست بحاجه الى مساعده من
حلف الناتو او من اي منظمات دوليه اخرى
لتقوم باستخدام حقها بارتفاع عن الذات لان
هناك
انتهاك واضح
قبل سوريا باسقاط الطائره المقاتله
ولذلك تركيا تحاول الرد باسلوب مسؤول
يراعي الشرعيه والقانون الدوليين وهذا
يعني بان تركيا ستقرر الهيكليه والشكل
والطريقه التي تحددها تركيا وليس كما يحدد
ذلك اي طرف دولي اذا قد ننتظر ربما لرد
محدد ربما يكون عسكريا في طبيعته من قبل
تركيا لا ادري متى سيكون ذلك ولكن ربما في
وقت قريب حسب ما اعتقد محمد عبيد في بيروت
كيف يمكن ان تنظر دمشق الى
هذه التهديدات التي وردت على اللسان
اردوغان والتي اتسمت بكثير من القوه
والجديه
مواقف اردوغان الكلاميه ليست جديده هناك
تجربه حصلت مثلا مع كيان العدو الاسرائيلي
فيما يعني سفينه مرمره ولم يتجاوز الموقف
التركي الذي عبر عنه اردوغان سوى الكلام
يعني العالي النبره انما من دون اي
اجراءات عمليه بالنسبه لسوريا سوريا
تعاملت ببروده مع هذا الموضوع انطلاقا من
علمها ويقينها ان تركيا ليست
صاحبه قرار مستقل على مستوى القيام
بمواجهه عسكريه او بحرب لانها جزء من حلف
دوله تقوده الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وعنوانه النوت الناتو بينما سوريا اليوم
اصبحت راس حربه في المحور الدولي المقابل
الذي تقوده روسيا والصين وبالتالي هذه
المساله لم تعد مساله بين سوريا وتركيا هي
صارت مساله بين محورين دوليين
مطمئنه الى ان الموقف التركي لن يتجاوز
الكلام اردوغان حاول اليوم ان يستجمع
موقفا وطنيا من خلال
حديثه في البرلمان التركي مع يقيينه بان
الكثير من قوى المعارضه التركيه
لا تؤازره ولا تناصره في اي مواجهه مع
سوريا اضافه الى جزء كبير من الشعب التركي
حاول ان يستجمع موقفا عربيا واسلاميا من
خلال حديثه عن الدوله السلجوقيه وعن
الدوله الايوبيه وعن العثمانيين في موضوع
القدس انما هذا الكلام لن يمر هذا الكلام
لن يؤدي الى اي نتيجه
اعتقد ان ما صدر اليوم من مواقف لجهه
روسيا او الناتو روسيا اكدت ان ما قامت به
سوريا ليس عملا استفزازيا وبالتالي من
الواضح ان روسيا دعمت سوريا
في الجزء الثاني من هذه الحلقه لو سمحت
استاذ عبيد ولكن نبقى فيها في هذه المرحله
اتوجه هنا الى العميد صفوت زياد عندما
يقول اردوغان العميد الزيات اذا اقدمت
سوريا على عمل مماثل او اقترب اي هدف سوري
من الحدود التركيه فان الجيش التركيه سيرد
وبذلك تتغير قواعد الاشتباك ماذا يعني
بهذه العباره الاخيره تحديدا تغيير او
تغير قواعد الاشتباك
يعني دعني اذكرك انه في يوم تسعه ابريل
الماضي كان هناك اطلاق نار عبر الحدود
لاول مره على مخيم كيليس في الطريق ما بين
اعزاز السوريه وعنتاب التركيه والتزم
الجيش التركي بعدم اطلاق النار الحديث
الان ان قواعد للشباك تغيرت يعني اننا
سنكون امام ضربات انتقائيه سواء
بالمدفعيات بعيده المدى او بالطيران
التركي
المتفوق ربما تفوقا ساحقا في هذه المعادله
ربما اذا شاهدنا مره اخرى مره اخرى اسقاط
طائره تركيه او محاوله لاصابه طائره قد
نشات عمليات جويه لازاله جزء من قواعد
الصواريخ المضاده للطائرات على الساحل
فيما بين اللاذقيه وطرتوس الرئيس التركي
الان ربما عدا الاتراك بعد دعم من النيتو
قد لا يتحدث عن عمليات عسكريه مباشره ولكن
الضوء الاخضر جيد للغايه في انه سيقوم برد
فعل لن يكتفي فقط برد على على مصادر النار
ولكن قد نشاهد ضربات انتقائيه ربما
ينتظرها العالم وستدعمها ربما القوه
الكبرى ربما ضد تشكيلات ميدانيه كبيره
وتشكيلات ميدانيه متوسطه وضد مرابط
لصواريخ الدفاع الجوي وفي هذه الحاله
سيبدا ما يمكن ان نقول له اول الدفاع
يؤكد انه الى حد الان لا تدخل عسكري او لا
رد عسكري لا من جانب تركيا ولا من جانب
الحلف ككل
النيت وعودنا دائما حاله من الانضباط في
الادبيات التي تصدر عنه ودعينا نكرر تجربه
ما حدث في ليبيا على الجميع الا يختبر
ربما اراده
غير قابل التكرار في الحاله السوريه
سيقولون هذا ولكن علينا ان ندرك جميعا ان
هناك خطط تعد وحتى طلعت الطائره التي
اصيبت واسقطت ربما تتم في مجرى طلعات
الاستطلاع الالكتروني لرسم خريطه للبثه
الرادارى على طول الساحل السوري هناك على
مدار الساعه بيتم اعداد قوائم اهداف هناك
خطط عمليات مبدئيه ربما موضوعه امام
الرئيس اوباما وامام القاده الكبار في
النيتو النيتو لن يتخذ قرار حرب او تدخل
بمجرد اجتماع لمجلس الاطلس ولكن قرار يتم
في الجانب العسكري لما حدث ارجوا ان نختصر
حتى نشرحها ونبسطها ثم اعود الى افق على
طاش لاحقا يعني هناك قناعه على نطاق واسع
بان ما جرى لم يكن عشوائيا او عرضيا وانما
كان نوع من
الاختبار التركي لرده الفعل السوريه ردت
عليها سوريه باستعراض للقوه هل يمكن ان
يكون هذا ما حدث فعلا في حادثه الطائره
دعيني اقول لك وربما نستطيع ان نقول ان
ربما المستشارين السوفيتي الذين يقومون
بتشغيل انظمه صواريخ حديثه مثل سامح 11 او
نظام ما يسمى ببوك ام اثنين قد يكونون هم
على هذه الدرجه العاليه من التقنيه
والفعاليه الفائقه التي اسقطت هذه الطائره
حديث المتحدث باسم وزاره الخارجيه السوريه
يتحدث عن اسقاط بمدفعيه عيار 23 مللي على
مسافه اثنين او ثلاثه كيلو متر من الشاطئ
السوري لكن عندما يتحدث السيد اردوغان ان
ربما بقايا او حطام الطائره عثر عليها في
داخل المياه السوريه ولكن على مسافه عشره
و11 كلم ربما هذا يؤشر انها استخدم منظومه
صواريخ احاديث ووردها الروس وربما قد تكون
رساله ضمنيه من الروس النيتو او للولايات
المتحده الامريكيه انكم ستواجهون صعبا جما
عندما يفكرون في انشاء ما يسمى نوفلايزون
او مناطق حظر جوي او تفكرون في مناطق سيف
زون او مناطق امنه داخل الحدود السوريه هي
رسائل متبادله ولكن الجميع ينتظر حدث كبير
مجزره كبيره او خلافه عند ذلك اعتقد ان
النيتو والغرب وقوه اخرى بكل ما يتصوره
البعض من انها ثوابت في المعادله الدوليه
مطروح وكما ذكرت روسيا وحلف النيتو لاعبا
اساسيان ماذا يمكن ان يكون دورهما في
تهدئه او تصعيد الموقف مستقبلا نناقش ذلك
بعد فاصل قصيره ارجو ان تبقوا معنا
اهلا بكم من جديد الى هذه الحلقه التي
تناقش
السيناريوهات ما قد يعقب حادثه الطائره
التركيه التي اسقطتها سوريا ودور كل من
روسيا وحلف الناتو المحتمل في هذه
السيناريوهات وفوق لوطاش
كثيرون ربما استغربوا عدم ردوخ اردوغان
للضغوط الكثيره التي مارستها قطاعات كبيره
من المعارضه وحتى من المواطنين
الاتراك العاديين من اجل الرد بقوه وبسرعه
على سوريا هل يمكن ان يكون اردوغان ردخا
بالاحرى
لرغبات النيتو واشنطن والاكتفاء في هذه
المرحله بهذا الرد الذي بدا هادئا ولكنه
غير ضعيف كما اكد
تركيا ومنذ البدايه لا تريد للنيتو ان
يشارك في الجهود المتعلقه بسوريا فتركيا
من البدايه ضد التدخل العسكري في سوريا
والسبب الذي جعل تركيا تلجا ليس لطلب
المساعده
لتدخل العسكري في سوريا فالكل في تركيا ضد
التدخل العسكريه في سوريا والسبب الذي جعل
تركيا تلجا هو ان توجز النيتو بشان ما جرى
في سوريا وتطلع النيتو على حقيقه الامور
المتعلقه بهذه الطائره التي اسقطت اذا
فالرد والجواب لن يكون على شكل تدخل عسكري
على الاقل هذا ما تريده تركيا ان لا يكون
التدخل عسكريا في سوريا نحن هنا نتحدث عن
رد محدود
وكما اشار احد الضيفين فهو لا يقرا المعار
تركيا بشكل خاطئ فالكل يعتقدوا فيه تركيا
بانه يجب ان يكون هناك رد حاسم ضد سوريا
بسبب اسقاط الطائره ولكن الكثيرين في
تركيا ضد التحرك العسكري ولكنهم رغم ذلك
يطلبون من الحكومه من رئيس الوزراء ان يرد
بشكل قوي على النظام السوري وهذا يشمل
الاحزاب المعارضه اذا لا يجب ان نخطئ
بقراءه المعارضه التركيه
وكما قلت ان الرد سيكون محدودا واذا كنتم
تعلمون المناطق الحدوديه بين تركيا وسوريا
فان الطائرات
السوريه او الدبابات يمكن رؤيتها من
الجانب التركي وهي شبه يومي تقترب من
البلدات القريبه من الحدود التركيه اذا
بتغييره مفهوم التهديد من وجهه نظر تركيا
وتغيير قواعد الاشتباك من قبل تركيا فان
هذا يعني ان اقتراب الوحدات العسكريه
السوريه التي يجري كل يوم قد يخلق الان
صراعا
واشتباكا محدودا بين تركيا وسوريا ولكن
ثانيه التدخل العسكري هذا امر لا يريده
الشعب ولا المعارضه ولا الحكومه في تركيا
ولكنهم كلهم يريدون ردا محدودا قويا عن
النظام السوري بسبب ما قام به النظام
السوري لهذه الطائره وبسبب انتهاك
السوريين للقانون الدولي محمد عبيد في
بيروت هل تعتقد ان دمشق تحتمي
بالاسطوله الروسي في طرطوس لذلك يعني
ردت بهذه الجراه واسقطت طائره تركيا
هناك اكثر كما عبر سابقا وزير الخارجيه
الروسي سرجالا بروف بان هناك اكثر من 100
الف روسي موجودين في سوريا وبالتالي جزء
كبير من هؤلاء هم جزء من الحاله العسكريه
الروسيه من الخبراء الروس الذين يديرون
مجموعه من منظومات الصواريخ والاسلحه
الاستراتيجيه الموجوده في سوريا الى جانب
الوجود العسكري الروسي على السواحل
السوريه سوريا طبعا مطمئنه الى تحالفها مع
روسيا ومع الصين وقد ثبت ان هذا التحالف
قد حمى سوريا في مجلس الامن الدولي وهو
يحميها اليوم والدليل ان الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه حتى هذه اللحظه
الان تحترم
عفوا طبعا ليس مساله حمايه هي جزء من هذه
المنظومه روسيا اليوم قالت بشكل واضح
اسقاط الطائره ليس عملا استفزازيا
وبالتالي دعمت سوريا بينما حلف الناتو لم
يقل سوى ان هذا الامر غير مقبول ليس هناك
توازن عمليا بين المحورين في دعم لان
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ما زالت تراهن
على تعاون دبلوماسي عميق مع روسيا في حل
سياسي للازمه السوريه ولان الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه لم تعطي الضوء الاخضر
لتركيا للتحرك ولان الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه تريد انجاح مؤتمر جناب مؤتمر
مجموعه الاتصال الدوليه الذي تجري الان
المباحثات حوله في جنابه التي تصر ايضا
روسيا على اشراك ايران في هذا المؤتمر
لذلك طبعا روسيا هي عفوا سوريا هي جزء من
محور دوله واقليمي ولا ننسى دور الجمهوريه
الاسلاميه الايرانيه الذي دون ادنى شك
سيشكل
ضغطا كبيرا على تركيا لعدم التحرك العسكري
باتجاه ايران المساله
تتجاوز سوريا وتركيا كلنا يعلم ان
الدبابات كما قال ضيفك من انقره ان
الدبابات السوريه والاسلحه السوريه تتحرك
على الحدود السوريه التركيه ولم يكن هناك
اي رد فعل تركي حتى الان مقابل هذا التحرك
اتت مساله اسقاط الطائره لم نسمع من
الجانب التركي سوى التهديدات والكلام عن
ان هذا الموضوع سيكون عليه رد في وقت ما
او تحتفظ تركيا بحق الرب انا اعتقد ان لم
يكن هناك ضوء اخضرا امريكيا باي عمل عسكري
يمكن ان تقوم لو كان هناك اجماع حتى لو
كان هناك
لن يتم الامر تمام مثل هذا المنطق
رغم عمل يعني وحاولات التلطيف من جانب
الحكومه السوريه لكن يعني هذه الطريقه في
التفكير لا يمكن ان تستفز تركيا
وتوجه لها رساله مضم انكم كما فعلتم
وتحدثتم وصعدتم اللهجه مع اسرائيل انتم
تفعلون شيء نفس الان ضد سوريا ولكنكم لم
تذهبوا ابعد من ذلك وقد ياتي مثل هذا
المنطق برد فعل معاكس تماما من جانب تركيا
سيدتي سيدتي نحن نحلل خلفيات الامور
وخلفيات وكواليس اتخاذ القرار ليس هناك
حتى اليوم قرار لدى الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ولد حلف الناتو ولا كثير من دول
العالم بالتدخل العسكريا انعد عن ان هذا
الامر مستحيل في ظل التوازنات الجديده
التي بدات كلنا سمع وزير الخارجيه الروسي
حين قال ان النظام العالمي الجديد الان
يعاد تكوينهم انطلاقا من سوريا المساله لم
تعد مساله اسقاط نظام ومعارضه ومسلحين هنا
وهناك صارت علم يعني في مدى اوسع صارت
جزءا من اعاده توازن اقليمي ودولي تقوده
روسيا والص وفيه ايران وسوريا ودول اخرى
في العالم العربي الى جانب المحور الاخر
العميد صفوت الزيات لو ركزنا قليلا على
عباره قواعد الاشتباك تغيرت وانه اي
اقتراب من
اقتراب اي هدف سوري من الحدود التركيه
يجبر الجيش التركي على الرد هل يمكن ان
يفهم منه ربما
اطلاق يد الجيش الحر الان من الحدود
التركيه بشكل اكبر
تجد نفس سوريا امام معاذ عن التحرك حتى لا
تواجه اي رد من الجيش التركي
يعني انا طبعا يعني باحزن كثيرا جدا عندما
تبني دوله ربما تصرفاتها وسلوكياتها
السياسيه والعسكريه على دعم قوى كبرى اخرى
ودعيني اقول لك لم يكن هناك علاقه اكثر من
العلاقه الوطيده ما بين صربيا وما بين
روسيا بينما قام الرئيس بيل كلينتون في
يوليو 95 بشن حمله جويه في اثناءها ايضا
خسفت ودمرت السفاره الصينيه في قلب
العاصمه بلغراد فدعيني اقول ان على الجميع
ان يدرك شكل التوازنات ولا يتصور ان القوه
الدوليه ستخاطر بمواجهه مع بعضها ربما من
اجل تصرف ربما غير منضبط هذه النقطه
النقطه التي اركز عليها ان قواعد للشباك
تعني ان الجيش السوري التركي سيفتح
النيران مره اخرى على اي مصادر نيران او
اي اختراقات قد تكون شبه اختراقات او
اختراقات فعليه للحدود التركيه سيحاول في
الفتره القادمه ربما الصناعه بعض
المواجهات للتعامل مباشره مع تشكيلات
ميدانيه مدرعه داخل الحدود السوريه وربما
فيها اسقاط لبعض الطائرات ولكن المهم الذي
اريد ان اقولها في النهايه نحن امام نظام
سوري مختنق استراتيجيا النظام السوري
مختلف استراتيجيا لا يسيطر الان على اكثر
من اقل من 30% من مناطق الشمال السوري
الان قتال في
منطقه الحدود
اسفه جدا مضطره للوقوف عند هذه النقطه
شكرا جزيلا لك العميد صفوت الزيات كنت
معنا من القاهره واشكر ايضا من بيروت
السياسي والعالميه اللبناني محمد عبيد ومن
ان ترى افق اولتاش الخبير في الشؤون الشرق
الاوسط بمركز سته لدراسات الاستراتيجيه
لذا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء
الخبر نلتقي باذن الله في قراءه جديده
فيما وراء خبر جديد غدا تحيه لكم اينما
كنت